-You're one of my faves.
-Likewise.
-I was looking at your résumé.
I'm looking through your stuff.
And you've been acting
for 20 years?
-Yeah. 20 years this year.
-You're not even 20 years old.
-I'm only 25, yeah.
I'm only 25.
-But that's wild.
-I know.
It's a little crazy to me.
It was funny.
When I was 10 years old --
I was 5 years old, and I
realized -- I was like --
I looked at my mom
and I was like,
"When I'm 10, am I gonna get
my tenure?"
-Oh, is that right?
-I thought that tenure was
ten-year.
-Ten year, yeah.
"Am I gonna get my tenure?"
-And it was not true.
-No, it's not.
I have a picture of you
from your --
You were in "The Amityville
Horror," by the way.
-Yes.
This was my first feature film.
[ Audience aws ]
-At age 5, were you even allowed
to see this movie?
-I was not allowed to see
this movie at all.
-Oh, here's you and Ryan
Reynolds, who was in the movie.
-Look at that little,
huge smile.
[ Laughter ]
-He's so happy.
-She's very excited.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. It was really funny
because most of my career
at that age, I was doing kind of
more R-rated or PG-13 movies.
So my mom would have to wait
until the movies came out on DVD
and then do, like,
a little highlights reel.
And so just kind of fast-forward
and show me -- just me --
which is like 10 minutes.
-Yeah, and then you'd never got
to see any movie
you were ever in.
-Yeah. Exactly.
-You know, every time you're
here, you always teach me about
a new hobby
that you're getting into.
And this time, I go,
"Are you into anything new?"
And you go, "Yeah."
-Yeah.
-Dirt bikes.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-No, this is scaring me.
Like, look at this.
This is how cool you look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, guys.
Thank you very much.
-What got you into it?
How long have you been doing it?
-So I grew up kind of
doing ATVs, but I was never
allowed to dirt bike.
My mom was super against it.
So obviously I grew up and I was
like, "I'm gonna do it."
I'm going to immediately
go for it.
-That's what every kid does.
-Yeah, exactly.
But it's really like -- The
thing is is when I'm on contract
and filming, I'm not allowed to
do anything dangerous.
You can't roller blade
or anything.
-Yeah.
-So when I'm off contract,
I'm like, "Let's go for it."
And this is the latest one.
-Oh, my gosh.
I mean, but it doesn't scare you
at all to go that fast?
For me, I'm just like --
I don't want anything fast.
-I really like going fast.
And I actually really want to
get into, like -- I want to try
to do, like, motocross jumps,
which are kind of scary.
-Yeah.
-So I had my version of
my first motocross jump
very recently last week.
And I flew over this thing,
and I felt that it was
the biggest jump
anyone had ever done.
-You actually brought video
to show our audience tonight.
Here's Chloe Grace Moretz
attempting
her first dirt bike jump.
Check this out.
-Yeah.
[ Engine revving ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did we get to -- Did we get to
the -- Did we get to the part?
-He's laughing. It was so loud.
-Did we get to the part
where you jumped?
[ Laughter ]
-I -- You seriously -- I think I
flew way more than the bike.
I was like, "Whoa!"
-Thank you for bringing
that video.
That's crazy.
That's pretty cool.
I want to talk about about
"The Peripheral," by the way.
-Yes.
-I love the premise.
Can we explain what this series
is about?
-Yeah, it's about a young woman
named Flynne Fisher,
and she lives in a small town
in the Appalachian Mountains.
And basically she video-games
for a living.
She plays simulation games.
And she plays it for
wealthy folks who pretty much
want them to level up
their avatars -- wants her
to level up the avatars.
And so one day, she thinks she's
beta-testing a new headset.
And she puts it on, and
immediately she realizes that
she's not operating
a simulation game
but she's operating a robot body
in the year 2099 in London.
-That's what I'm talking about.
-Yeah.
So it's really great.
-You realize you're not playing
a video game.
"Wait a second.
This is actually real."
-Yeah. And she basically becomes
a little bit of
a government pawn.
And so it's trying to figure out
how she can figure out the world
that she's been placed in,
which has real-world problems
in the sense that people in her
time in 2032 are now trying to
come and kill her
and her family.
-I think it's fantastic.
I love the idea. It's so good.
And you were telling me
there's a lot of action
sequences in this.
And you were saying, yeah, you
tried to learn judo, was it?
-Yeah, judo.
-Since, what, from "Kick-Ass"?
-Yeah, so I started doing
martial arts
when I was 11 in "Kick-Ass."
And I got to train for --
[ Single cheer ]
Yeah, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
I got to train -- It's cool.
Martial arts is tight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And for this one, our wonderful
stunt coordinator,
Tony, he's a master judo
champion.
And he really wanted me to get
into it.
And I was super down because it
means I can throw 160-,
180-pound men just, like, over
my shoulder and just fly them,
which sounds so fun.
-Yeah. You can do that.
-Yes.
-And thank goodness we're not
doing it to me.
But you brought video as well.
-I did offer.
I was like,
"I will do it to you."
[ Laughter ]
We don't have to do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do it!
-I mean, you want to do it?
-No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can you?
Am I going to get hurt?
-I don't think so.
You might get hurt.
-I might get hurt?
-Do it!
-I mean, do you want to?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Where do I land?
What do I have to do?
-You can land on the couch.
-I can land on the couch?
-Yeah, watch this.
Okay, come here.
-Uh-huh. Seriously, we did not
rehearse this.
-No, we did not rehearse this.
Okay, put your arm up.
-You know I love you. I'm a fan.
[ Laughter ]
-Put your arm up.
-Uh-huh.
-And then I'm going to go
underneath you.
And you're going to come around.
And then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm too old!
I'm too old to be thrown!
Here's a clip from
"The Peripheral."
Here's Chloe Grace Moretz.
Check it out.
-Don't care to lecture me
about pain.
-Well, I don't want to
lecture you.
I just want to snap
your [bleep] neck.
-[ Chuckles ]
Do you feel it?
Darkness closing in.
Let it be preparation for when I
kill you and it's real.
-I got a foothold
in your world now.
So next time I'll be coming
for you instead.
-Yeah, that's how you do it
right there!
Chloe Grace Moretz, everybody.
New episodes of "The Peripheral"
are available Fridays
on Prime Video.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Bruce
Springsteen. Stick around.